ja wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung zum
seminar interdisziplinäre perspektiven
heute geht es vor allem um die frage
nach der ethik von künstlicher
intelligenz auch um die frage wie
künstliche intelligenz urteilen kann
inwiefern sie moralisch sensibel sein
kann wir hatten schon eine sitzung der
wir ähnliche fragen diskutiert hatten
ich mache da oben rechts den link rein
heute geht es vor allem um ein buch von
julian nida-rümelin mit dem titel
digitale humanismus und darin finden
sich interessante thesen die wollen wir
heute
diskutieren aber zunächst gibt es einen
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung in der
wir uns mit dem thema künstliche
intelligenz und trans man ismus gefasst
haben dann mache ich auch oben rechts
den link wieder rein für youtube um was
ging es wir hatten uns mit ray kurzweil
fast einem sehr begnadeten erfinder und
techniker ich habe ein paar
informationen zu sein leben gegeben zu
sein erfindungen diese kurzweil reading
maschinen die wirklich ganz bedeutend
ist für die
barrierefreiheit sehbehinderter menschen
dann hatte ich erwähnt dass es hier auch
wenn er ein kurzwahl music system gibt
die der versuch klänge naturgetreue zu
simulieren vielleicht auch zu
realisieren also hier stellt sich auch
wieder die frage simulation oder
duplikation
auch beim musikalischen
technischen phänomenen
auch hatte ich erwähnt dass es diese
singularity university gibt und hier ist
dann schon der stichpunkt genannte
stichwort genannt singularität es gibt
dieses buch in singularity ist mir das
gilt als eines der wichtigsten werke des
transform annis muss was transfers muss
ist werde ich noch mal kurz erklären
ganz wichtig im zusammenhang der
singularität ist auch die kurve des
exponentiellen wachstums singularität
und exponential i tät
hängen ganz irgendwie nahe zusammen ich
will jetzt hier mal noch ein anderes
buch kurz nehmen page of spirit of
machines das ist was ganz noch mehr
künstliche intelligenz betrifft hier
ging es um die frage inwiefern wie auch
unsterblich werden wie finden wir
menschen unser geist unsere personale
identität nur im sinne von software
verstanden werden kann und ich möchte
ein paar punkte problematische punkte
nochmals
herausarbeiten zu dem thema tanz
humanismus wer sich dafür noch
intensiver interessiert zudem mache ich
auch oben rechts den link zu einer
vorlesungsreihe über anthropologie der
digitalität letzte woche ging es um das
thema tanz journalismus ein bisschen
ausführlicher ich möchte hier noch mal
kurz vorstellen der trans man ismus
extrapoliert auf künftige entwicklung
durch analogien und prognosen also er
legt meistens ein schema zu grunde eine
funktion die ist exponentiell und die
reicht natürlich nur bis in die
gegenwart um bestätigt zu werden und
alles was in die zukunft darüber hinaus
geht das ist dann natürlich letztendlich
nur eine prognose
ganz interessant ist dass sich der trans
man is muss an der biologischen
evolutionstheorie orientiert und diese
durch eine technologische
evolutionstheorie erweitert in der
technik und mensch immer mehr
konvergieren oder mit anderen worten
gesprochen in der die technische
evolution
die natürliche evolution fortsetzt hier
ist noch ein wichtiger punkt zu bemerken
nämlich der dass die technologie in der
auffassung des tanz humanismus sich
selbst rechtfertigt also es geht dabei
nicht dass hier um den gebrauch von
technologien sondern die technologie hat
in sich eine gewisse normativität sie
ist aufs gute ausgerichtet das ist
natürlich ein großer optimismus technik
optimismus auf den ich auch noch genauer
eingehen werden was nur entscheidend ist
es dass durch diese biologistische
technizistischen auffassung
natürlich eine nähe zur künstlichen
intelligenz hergestellt weil künstliche
neuronale netze ja auch ganz stark
diesen biologistischen nach bildungs
charakter haben das gerät sollte durch
in einer gewissen form natürlich sehr
statisch und dokumentieren nachgebildet
werden das es so bis sie die bezugs
basis unser gehirn und hier liegt
natürlich dann die nähe auf der hand
dass man sagen kann künstliche neuronale
netze sind eine form der technischen
technologischen revolution die aus der
biologischen hervorgeht weil sie
bestimmte muster aufgreift und weiter
perfektioniert oder ebenfalls konsequent
fort führt das scheint mir ganz wichtig
zu sein ich hatte schon im winter dran
zu machen muss besitzt spekulative züge
die sind einfach deswegen vorhanden weil
es um die prognosen geht beim prognosen
die einen exponentiellen wachstum folge
und damit einher gehe dann auch ein
ideologischer charakter des konsumismus
weil er ebenso technik affin ist und so
positiv über technik denkt wie ich schon
sagte technik rechtfertigt sich selbst
nach dem transfer mannis muss das ist
natürlich eine ideologie man könnte
genauso sagen technik schade der welt
auch das ist natürlich eine ideologien
dieser einfach vor mich darf hier martin
heidegger und hinweisen auf ihn seine
rede von dem gestell wer sich dafür
interessiert ganz spannend dass
techniken das gestell was in eine
differenz zur lebenswelt und zur natur
tritt auch das ist in meinen augen zu
verkürzt wir müssen uns irgendwo der
mitte treffen wir müssen eine
lebensweltliche integrative auffassung
von technologie entwickelt auch speziell
jetzt von künstlicher intelligenz der
sich für seine these interessiert dann
mache ich auch oben rechts und
interessantes video rein jedenfalls hat
der trans man ismus ideologische züge
weil er eben viel zu optimistisch fast
schon es kato logisch an diese
entwicklung herangeht dass dadurch die
rettung auch eventuelle der mensch
besteht also julian nida-rümelin spricht
von einem quasi religiösen ansatz des
traditionalismus und ich habe ja schon
gesagt er ist techno optimistisch und
auch perfektionistisch also er geht
davon aus der trance mann ist dass wir
uns den menschen zu verbessern
also nicht nur im sinne des
instrumentalen denkens schneller höher
weiter sind auch im moralischen das
scheint seine prämisse zu sein und die
kann man natürlich mit guten argumenten
bestreiten warum sollten in folge der
technischen
fortschritt und entwicklung auch die
welt moralisch besser werden wir können
ja auch die technik einsetzen zum
schlechten und es gibt sicherlich auch
konsequenzen der technik die die klima
schädigung und soweit die einfach
negative nebeneffekte haben also technik
scheint doch als solche erst mal neutral
zu sein vielleicht durchaus progressiv
aber wir müssen sie immer kritisch
begleiten und sollten sie nicht ihren
gang nehmen lassen wieso eine
technizistischen
evolutionstheorie argumentieren sie muss
immer begleitet werden technische
evolution durch eben kritische
reflexionen insofern versteht sich eben
auch die trans humanismus als eine
bewegung die aufklärung die technik als
mittel der aufklärung und das möchte ich
auch damit auch ein fragezeichen hinter
machen technik hat sicherlich
aufklärerische moment aber technik kann
auch dazu beitragen die aufregung zu
vermeiden oder zu verhindern durch
verdunkelung durch die entwicklung von
scheinen also auch hier müssen wir uns
dazu verhalten und die technik als
solche ins erste mal doch weder positiv
noch negativ sondern einfach nur eine
form der reflexion die dann so oder so
eingesetzt werden kann ja jetzt komme
ich auf das heutige thema zu sprechen da
geht es jetzt noch einmal konkret und
ethik der künstlichen intelligenz und
zwar wie ich schon sagte anhand dieses
buches von julian nida-rümelin und
natalie weidenfeld digitalis muss eine
ethik für das zeitalter der künstlichen
intelligenz was hier auffällt ist dass
das digitale sehr
eingebunden wird fast schon reduziert
wird auf künstliche intelligenz das kann
man natürlich auch in frage stellen die
ganze digitalisierung oder auch die
vitalität wie man das so schön nennt
nach oben rechts link zu der playlist
meiner vorlesung über philosophie der
digitalität ob sich digitalität nur auf
künstliche intelligenz reduzieren lässt
das scheint jetzt ein bisschen angelegt
zu sein und das möchte ich auch
bestreiten künstliche intelligenz
künstlichen landet sie sind bestimmt
eine ganz interessante
phänomen erscheinung der digitalisierung
aber machen lang nicht das ganze wesen
aus dieser tendenz das scheint mir eben
sehr wichtig zu sein ich möchte jetzt
hier mal ein zitat vorlesen was mir sehr
zentral zu sein scheint k s hat julian
nida-rümelin handeln nicht nach eigenen
gründen sie haben keine gefühle kein
moralisches empfinden keine intention
und sie können diese anderen personen
auch nicht zu schreiben ohne diese
fähigkeiten ist eine angemessene
moralische praxis nicht möglich um eine
berechtigte von einem unberechtigten
bitte unterscheiden zu können ist es
erforderlich die bitten die person
richtig einzuschätzen ihre motive zu
erkennen und die ihre interessen lage zu
berücksichtigen auch die besonderen
verpflichtungen gegenüber nahestehenden
lassen sich nur auf der grundlage
geteilter intensität das ist ein
wichtiges stichwort internationale tee
und geteilte emotionen bestimmen dem
thema emotion hatten wir uns nach der
letzten sitzung befasst ich mache auch
oben rechts wie links rein selbst das
motiv des wohlwollens setzt ein gewisses
maß an empathie voraus die fähigkeit
sich in die empfindung schlagen andere
hineinzuversetzen seine computer nicht
über quartier also subjektiven
bewusstseinszustände verfügt gehen ihm
die entscheidenden in kriens moralischen
urteilskraft ab er verfügt nicht über
moralische urteilskraft sondern könnte
diese allenfalls simulieren hier ist
wieder die frage simulation oder
duplikation mit der urteilskraft müssen
wir uns dann heute noch genauer
beschäftigen es gibt ja verschiedene
formen von urteilskraft ästhetische
urteilskraft aber eben auch moralischen
urteilskraft im amerika tier eine kritik
der urteilskraft verfasst und ich habe
da auch so ein paar an sich die nation
darüber wollen wir heute diskutieren und
wir legen der diskussion drei leitfragen
zugrunde die beziehen sich auf den text
von julian nida-rümelin erste frage
warum können roboter keine moralischen
urteilskraft es sitzen zweite frage
warum kann kann nicht denken jetzt
natürlich auch an die klärung der frage
was überhaupt ging ist und drittens nie
sollte eine ethik der
mensch-maschine-interaktion
gestaltet sein nach dieser auffassung
des digitalen humanismus